you've heard of brain plasticity this is
the incredible ability of the brain to
adapt to its environment
resulting in new and strengthened neural
pathways
far less talked about is muscle
plasticity this is surprising
given that muscle plasticity is probably
the biggest factor contributing to your
physique and athletic performance
muscle plasticity is defined as the
ability of a given muscle to alter its
structural and functional properties
in accordance with the environmental
conditions imposed on it
in short a more plastic muscle is more
prone to hypertrophy
and other structural changes it is
simply more responsive to training
this is the difference between hard
gainers and the genetically fortunate
muscle plasticity is also responsible
for differences in muscle fiber type
some people have a tendency towards
slower endurance type
type 1 muscle fibers others have a
higher ratio
of type 2 fast twitch muscle fiber but
that fiber can also be changed
so put it this way you might be an
endurance type but if you have higher
muscle plasticity
you could more successfully make the
transition to a power type
in my book functional training and
beyond i describe plasticity
as a super trait that's because it's a
trait that can amplify every other trait
muscle plasticity is genetically
determined to an extent
but there are definite ways to beat the
odds i recently had my dna analyzed by
self-decode
and i learned that i had a desirable snp
for actn3
a gene that encodes actin in alpha 3 and
is related to fast twitch muscle fiber
as well as recovery and training
adaptation
you can find all the studies supporting
this stuff in the full article
over at the website this gene is
disproportionately represented in
athletes
and i can attest that i do respond very
rapidly to training i'd wager the same
is probably true for many of the fitness
influencers showing up on your instagram
feed
those with the opposite xx genotype
however may fare better in endurance
type activities
though i do also have a tendency towards
tendon injuries so there's that
self-knowledge though allows for smart
personalized training
and a tailored approach to diet and
supplementation it is a new frontier for
coaches and self-optimization
for example it may be possible to combat
the effects of deficient or average
actinin alpha 3 production
via carotenoid rich foods such as piqui
oil
if you're interested in finding out more
about your own genetic profile
and how it may impact your athleticism
personality and cognitive performance
not to mention allergies hair loss
susceptibility to illness and more
then you can follow the link in the
description below i actually get a bit
of commission if you use
that link so you'd also be supporting
the channel in a big way
if you've ever used ancestry or another
service that uses your dna
you can just download the file to get
immediate results i'll also include a
link to my own reports for cognitive and
athletic performance
check them out if you're at all
interested it's a cool service that i'm
definitely going to be discussing more
on the site in future
but that said there are others like it
if you want to shop around
and whether or not you won the genetic
lottery or choose to peek inside that
black box
there are many other ways to enhance
general muscle plasticity that should
work for everyone
here are some of the most interesting
and practical
one study suggests that over training at
least in rats
will reduce the production of anabolic
muscle transcription factors
such as myogen and myod and thus reduce
muscle growth
taking a break from training is the best
way to get these back so the muscles
become more plastic again
this may be why i've personally found
such success when taking week-long
breaks from training
every one or two months it feels
counter-intuitive but it's actually
highly effective at giving you that
bounce-back response working on cardio
could also
offer significant benefits here once
again running
regularly works wonders no matter your
goals while it's a little removed from
human gym goers
one encouraging study showed that
aerobic exercise could increase muscle
plasticity
in mice recovering from spinal cord
injuries my question is
how they got the mice with the spine
injuries to come forwards for the study
did they stick up little post-it notes
at a rat hospital
oh this was due to an increased
vascularization
more blood flow allows the muscles to
respond more effectively
to training presumably then we might
also expect to see training that focuses
on capillarization
such as bodybuilding style pump training
to effectively increase plasticity
this is speculation but it does gel with
what i've experienced myself and it
makes logical sense
this is why the super functional program
begins with a pump program that revolves
around high repetitions of isolation
movements
and the one routine that involves high
reps of calisthenics
we might similarly expect to see blood
flow restriction training aid with this
as this protocol also increases
capillary to muscle ratio
another key differentiator that
determines plasticity
is the baseline satellite cell count of
an individual
subjects with more satellite cells
experienced greater myonuclear addition
and far greater muscle growth some
interesting things you can do to
increase this effect include
supplementing with creatine and
increasing testosterone
you can also benefit from longer
training sessions and it seems that
training for increased capillarization
also enhances muscle satellite cell
proliferation
plasticity is also responsible for
recovery to a large extent
injury occurs when the environment
changes faster than the organism can
adapt
so if you can adapt faster you can
prevent injury and train harder
training is biphasic although you do the
work in the gym it is during rest and
sleep that your muscles grow thicker
and you reinforce those neural pathways
improving recovery is largely a matter
of improving your ability to rest and
eating right
getting lots of deep sleep makes a huge
difference as does avoiding stress
outside the gym
eat ample protein nutrients and calories
hydration is also extremely important
while light exercise such as walking can
be an effective way to improve delivery
of blood and nutrients
to recovering muscles raising
testosterone and other anabolic hormones
through diet exercise and sunlight
exposure
can once again also have a big impact on
recovery
what's also more important though is to
improve cardiovascular fitness
this will again aid with the delivery of
nutrients to the muscles
meditation is also hugely beneficial as
it helps to combat stress
which prevents us from entering the most
anabolic states certain forms of
meditation can even be used to make up
for lost sleep to a certain extent
again there are plenty of hacks and
novel strategies out there that claim to
enhance recovery
proceed with caution one weirdly is
hydrogen water
topical and oral administration of
hydrogen-rich water
appears to enhance soft tissue recovery
following injury
one review of the literature stated that
in a first trial a combination of oral
and topical h2
resulted in a faster return to normal
joint flexibility in 36 young men who
had suffered sports related soft tissue
injuries
when administered for 14 days as
complementary treatment to a traditional
medical protocol for soft tissue
injuries however it also recommended
taking the findings with a grain of salt
as they remain very limited in scope at
this stage
similarly there is a surprisingly high
amount of positive evidence
for the effectiveness of
photobiomodulation pbm
or light therapy as a means to both
prevent muscle injury
and enhance recovery in fact the results
are so good that there is some
discussion around whether athletes
should be allowed to use the method when
competing
this method stimulates mitochondrial
production and encourages more blood
flow
and collagen production heck there's
even a fair bit of evidence for whole
body cryo-stimulation for enhanced
recovery though i don't believe that
that falls into the category of
practical expect more in-depth
explorations of these topics for future
posts
to be clear though i'm not recommending
you go out and buy an expensive red
light panel
or start sitting in your freezer there
is not yet enough evidence for these
methods
and hacking is never as effective as
smart and
consistent training the point is though
that
being a hard gainer is not necessarily
something that you're stuck with
there might be ways that you can beat
the system
so i hope you found this video useful
and interesting guys if you did please
consider leaving a like and sharing it
around
that helps me out immensely subscribe if
you want to see more content like this
and hit the bell button to be notified
of new posts
are you a hard gainer and how have you
overcome that challenge let me know in
the comments
if you'd like to learn more about
functional training then check out my
book
functional training and beyond available
on amazon and at all good bookstores
sorry for the short supply before for
those in europe it turns out that the
issues were a brexit thing but it's all
sorted now i believe
it's also available on audible now for
those that prefer to listen
read by me no less alternatively if
you'd like a full training program that
incorporates concepts like pump training
and high rep calisthenics alongside
mobility strength training endurance and
even cognitive performance
be sure to check out my ebook and
training routine super functional
training
there's a link in the description and
it's on discount while we're dealing
with the pandemic
remember you can also check out self
decode and my own reports in the
description
either way thank you so much for
watching this one guys and i'll see you
next time
bye for now